all right no more contacts i just wanted
to have fun but i'm sick and tired
of my eyes fighting me like for 20
minutes and that's just putting them in
and then i review the movie like so
this is this movie uh yeah so yeah you
just get my
normal eyes how do my eyes look like
i've been messing with them for 20
minutes
i know but we start a new week of the
horror movie review extravaganza and
that means it's scream day
[Music]
scream 3 the concluding chapter of the
trilogy
i mean well as it was that we got
screamed for
guess we're getting scream five but
concluding chapter of the trilogy
nonetheless
sydney prescott's actually i just
i don't want to say living large but i
love her house like that's my dream when
youtube
burns or my channel gets destroyed i
would love to live
in a place like that just in the
mountains somewhere the point is
everyone thought the ghostface killings
were done and then cottonweary gets
offed at the beginning dude that number
one show called 100
cotton which is a brilliant name for his
show but he's pretty much like jerry
springer so at first people were like is
he just pissed people off and is that
just it but of course more ghostface
killing so the band gets back together
to help sydney and
so here we are and okay i mean i got to
give a couple dues that i haven't given
for the scream movies before because i
ramble i'm asked a lot like do you
script your reviews no
i just ramble but as i ramble sometimes
things get left behind and
overlooked and yeah that's my bad maybe
i should script them
but it probably won't because if i
script it it'll sound scripted i don't
want to sound scripted so so this is me
paying back some dues that got
overlooked before
all right first of all matthew lillard
in the original scream i actually
purposely didn't talk about him that
wasn't an overlook you know
for those two people out there who
hadn't seen scream one i didn't want to
spoil anything
i suppose i could have talked about
matthew lillard a little bit but now
that we're talking about scream three
hey spoilers also
spoiler for scream three look you don't
read the comments i do if i don't give
those disclaimers
i'm gonna hear about it give me a
nightmare but matthew lillard in the
original scream is amazing i cannot
think of an actor in a slasher movie
that had
more fun with being the killer in a
slasher movie i cannot see the cover of
my goblin's revenge book without seeing
his face he's crazy he's unhinged he's
kind of frightening
and he's hilarious in a word he's epic
also the scream soundtrack that marco
beltrami soundtrack i
have the record i have it on lp it's
amazing some of my favorite horror
movies out there
i can think of the theme right out the
gate you hear the first couple notes
you're like that's from that horror
movie i love the soundtrack whether it
be the main theme couple of the side
themes good stuff also screenwriter
kevin williamson he wrote scream one he
wrote scream two he did a great job
he did not write scream three and it
shows no matter what i say about scream
three in this review scream three still
has that line in which gayle weathers is
quoted saying pop culture is the
politics of the 21st century
nailed it there not that scream three
doesn't have some stuff going for it i
mean the returning cash is great nev
campbell david arquette courtney cox
they're all great because they've all
been great before
i feel like gail weathers courtney cox's
character i feel like she kind of
becomes this
needy girlfriend in this movie but i
can't deny in a
dumb fun way i guess when i just started
slipping into the fact i was like okay
scream three is
this kind of movie let's just go there i
had fun with the two gales
going around doing their investigative
[ __ ] but the returning cast had been
great before they're great now the
introduction of detective kincaid played
by patrick dempsey i thought he was a
good addition though this is the first
movie with only one killer
but if you look at detective king cade
he might have been the other killer i'm
not convinced he's not he has a whole
stalker file on sydney prescott that
just
could be called good police work could
also be called stalker vibes he shows up
at the mansion at the very end without
his partner he very well could have been
the second killer and then
you know when the killer turns on him
and smacks his head up against the
fireplace
maybe all bets were off at that point
maybe that might be a reveal in scream
five
i don't know but i'm just saying he at
least adds that kind of intrigue where
you're like what if he was a killer and
he just kind of got away with it just
scream three well scream is always about
family right if you look at
all the screen movies there's always a
family element at work in there but
whereas it could have wrapped up in
scream 2 and scream 2 was kind of the
end i feel like with scream three the
thought was
well we kind of have to keep going with
that plus we need a killer that somehow
is gonna pick up the ghostface
murders so let's just make [ __ ] up
and it did so the plot of scream three
is back in the day when maureen prescott
sydney's mom was like 19 years old she
had this secret life in hollywood for a
couple years
and then the producer of these grade b
slasher flicks he was known for having
parties at his place where girls could
meet
powerful dudes and those dudes can get
them roles in movies and so she was
sexually assaulted
right so and also this plot point is why
i don't even take hollywood people
seriously when they're like oh harvey
what
i had no idea harvey weinstein did that
[ __ ] cause like yeah you did
it was it was such an open thing in
hollywood it's a plot point in this
hollywood movie and no one blinked or
thought it was weird harvey weinstein
was even a producer on screen three so
yeah it was like such
open knowledge in hollywood that when
people like oh [ __ ] i had no idea i was
like shut the [ __ ] up yeah you did so
anyhow
it's kind of a side thought but back to
the review
so maureen prescott had a child and
years later when this dude became an
adult tracked her down she didn't want
anything to do with him so the dude was
pissed
and so the dude got billy loomis to kill
her and basically he was behind billy
loomis's motivation and everything from
the beginning
of course it's that kind of movie billy
loomis's own motivation that wasn't
enough you know you had to have this
other
villain you know the super boss behind
the boss the guy behind the guy
that made it all happen you know set
everything in motion i've just never
been a fan of that and this next thing
i don't know where this came from but
it's like they were like oh we've had
the voice box let's have the voice box
times 10. so this voice box can just
emulate anyone's voice which there is
tech out there that
can do that but you can still tell it's
a robot this is
pitch perfect this is someone's voice
enough to where
sydney is going to be framed at the ends
using that voice box so my question is
was this known tech out there did he
just make this voice box
because if he didn't make this thing
himself that means it's out there and
any detective would be like yeah but did
they use that voice synthesizer thing
that that's possible i don't know how he
got the voices other than they were like
well we need to be able to do that in
this movie to make this
ridiculous movie work so the movie just
has these conveniences that were written
in for the sake of like well we're not
really going to have a movie if we don't
write this ridiculous stuff in there's
even this one ridiculously convenient
kill in this movie you thought
sydney showing up to the stage at the
end of scream too you thought that was
convenient
i did you can't even quantify how
convenient this is though i'll give it
credit for
being one of the more interesting kills
because a lot of the kills in scream
three are very
blood lacking stab wounds but there's a
scene where the killer's faxing all the
stuff and rather than just you know what
we're running outside [ __ ] this calling
9-1-1 they're like no we need to stay
here and read this
novel that this fax machine's vomiting
out we're kind of invested at this point
so this guy's like oh the lights are out
and he
lights this lighter and it says the
killer will show mercy to the one who
smells the gas he's like
and he blows up because i guess there
was gas that he didn't smell that's like
how did what are the odds what is this
the movie paycheck
how did he know that what happened i'm
not saying this is the only movie that
has conveniences like that but the
difference is
between a movie that can hide it and a
movie that's just not even trying i also
enjoy the fact that randy's back in vhs
form but he's back to give the rules of
the trilogy which i love
but also this is another moment where
the movie starts
going too far into the meta and i half
expected them to realize they're in a
movie directed by wes craven because
randy says
one of the rules of the trilogy is that
if you're dealing with an unexpected
backstory and sydney's like oh [ __ ] i've
been having visions of my mom
it's just kind of crazy that she's like
oh i've just been having dreams about my
mom
obviously we're in the concluding
chapter of this trilogy see the rules of
surviving a horror movie as
said in the original scream by randy it
served to inform the audience about
horror movie formula the audience feels
informed also feels connected with the
movie as they're watching it because
it's what randy was saying is true even
the rules he brought up in scream 2
about the sequel
absolutely applicable because they're
very simple body counts always bigger
death scenes are always much more
elaborate absolutely true and absolutely
by the fact that randy would be listing
off the rules of this concluding chapter
of a trilogy
as he did in scream three the killer's
immortal and all that but scream three
actually does a cool thing with that
in which the killer looks immortal but
he has a bulletproof vest it's a simple
grounded real way of illustrating that
and it makes sense for the movie
sydney prescott randomly having dreams
and visions of her dead mother before
she knew the rules of the trilogy and
then she's like oh whoa i'm having
visions of my dead mom obviously because
it's one of the rules
we're stepping dangerously close to the
ethereal realm of premonition
it just seems out of place and scream
about as out of place
as jay and silent bob cameoing in scream
three no i'm not saying jason muse
and kevin smith cameo i'm saying jason
muse and kevin smith cameo as their
characters jade silent bob then wes
craven was in jay and silent bob strike
back and they parodied scream in one
scene do you feel like kevin smith and
wes craven were like well i'll be in
yours if you're in mine
the whole thing works for jay and silent
bob strike back because it's a giant
silent bob strike
back scream is not supposed to have that
jay in silent bob cross
promotion vibe going on and it altered
my perception on how i even see
scream three i mean at that point i was
like okay so this is just kind of
an inside joke among hollywood people
about hollywood that's what scream three
is and these are the ways scream three
is just
kind of becoming a parody of scream
it's more scary movie than it is scream
you know it's almost like it's spoofing
itself
see before scream three scream was
always a thriller horror
slasher movie with horror movie
commentary
first with some humor in it scream three
feels closer to a comedy slash
horror movie backlot parody with some
slasher movie elements in it just there
wasn't enough horror to offset those
other elements and really
you can kind of blame it on the time the
movie even addresses it which is a thing
that movies do when there's something
holding the movie back
when the characters address it it's like
it softens the blow
the director is told look violence in
movies is a big thing right now and it
was in the late 90s that conversation
ramped up because of real world violence
the scream 3
is a lot less bloody some of the
stabbings are off camera like emily
mortimer when she's getting stabbed
she's flailing around but you don't
actually see her getting stabbed just
like they were like look
you need to flail more because we can't
show you get stabbed
there's no scene like when sarah
michelle gellar gets stabbed and you see
the knife going in you're like
not that you don't see cotton weary get
stabbed at the beginning of the movie
it's probably one of the bloodier kills
a lot of the kills are just blood
lacking stabbings that aren't
interesting an easy way to judge is just
look at the light kills between scream
one and scream three
when the cameraman kenny when he got his
throat cut
fair amount of blood coming out of his
neck scream three lance henriksen's
character gets his throat cut a little
bit of blood then he gets thrown into
the round really in terms of violence
scream three
could have been a pg-13 movie so that's
what scream three is it's an
honorary pg-13 conclusion of the scream
trilogy look in the end by the end i
actually do appreciate scream 3 for the
fact that it does have a good sense of
finality you do feel like the story is
over the ghostface killings are done
sydney's story is wrapped up scream 3 is
just the moment where
it flew a little too close to the sun
got buried in its own meta world
became that sequel that was making [ __ ]
up to have a sequel made but not in that
ironic way that scream two did because
scream
two still tried to be horror regardless
if you're down to watch a scream trilogy
scream three would probably be a better
time
if you're drunk yeah now it's a party
all right so scream three have you seen
it what did you think about it is it the
weakest of the screams or is that scream
two maybe scream four or whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
you